from ESPN MLB Insider extraordinary our
front Jeff pass and returns the program
how are you Jeff what illustrious
company I'm keeping today rich you know
Jeff Jeff I don't I only I only know one
speed but you're in the Rickey Henderson
slot you're in the Rickey Henderson so
[Laughter]
no or just here's what you do you can
either knock it over the fence or you
can reach base and wind up on third by
the but you know two minutes into this
conversation that's either one you could
do either one if you're Rick Anderson so
honestly Rickey Rickey we get really
nostalgic these days right yep and I
look back on players of my youth and I
think Rickey Henderson was probably the
best player I saw growing up he was just
I would love to see Ricky play these
days where it's okay to pimp a home run
things that Ricky did anyway yes and
when it wasn't okay because he was Ricky
the snatch catch don't don't forget the
snatch catch don't forget no I mean
Ricky Ricky talked in the third person
when when talking in the third person
was was well you know talking in the
third person is actually always frowned
again the frowned upon isn't it
like if someone work like if somewhere
to talk about their adverse news days
would be like what are you doing talking
in the third person
you know what Ricky would still do it
Ricky didn't care Ricky
Howard Bryant my good friend who works
with me at ESPN is doing a Rickey
Henderson biography right pass and let
me tell you man I cannot wait neither
can I two things first Jeff you've only
called it to the show you've never
physically been here to our Los Angeles
Rich Eisen show studios and we look
forward to the day that you can make it
but I would introduce you to my audio
executive Mike Dell 2fo who refers to
himself as Dell 2fo so that's right so
you are the king of our third person I
love third person I mean I mean are we
talking like Dell to foes gonna get
lunch no I don't think so but don't it
was good yeah it's a lot of yeah it's a
yeah yeah self-congratulatory
yes it's self-congratulatory that's
number one and then before we move on
from the subject I love the fact that we
stumbled into this to start the story of
Rickey Henderson reaching base and
telling john olerude who wore a helmet
in the field because of his you know his
head injury that he had or was it
surgery or something like that
that that he told john olerude hey I
used to play with a guy I used to wear a
helmet playing first base and old would
turn to him and say that was me Ricky is
that a true story that really happened
that was the one the one the one that I
don't know yes if it's true or not and
I'm looking forward to the book to see
this because I'm sure Howard will talk
about it is like deep into his career
there was there was a seat that was
opened at the front of the bus and
somebody told Ricky to sit there and
Ricky's like why do you want me to sit
here and someone said to him because
you've got tenure and Ricky looked at
him and this is just I don't know if
this is a particle story or if it's true
Ricky looked at him and said I don't
have tenure I've been around for 20
years I mean he's in the telling and in
the telling of the story it's Ricky's
been around for 20 years you use the
third person and you would did he did
which one do you want to bring out Chris
was a story that Richie got Ricky got
like a million dollar bonus check or
something and he framed it instead of
cashing it that would be here's the
thing Ricky
like I don't know if they make them like
Ricky anymore knows you hear stories
about him and you believe all of them
are true because because they are they
are they are so ridiculous but the ones
that have actually been confirmed as
real are just as ridiculous so if you're
dealing with the ridiculous person why
is he going to act normal or rational it
goes against type you know it's a zebra
with the stripes
see this this story alone Jeff you're on
base batting leadoff man see and now
you're just you're now I'm need to keep
an eye on you because you're about to
take second and then third I just loved
it
I just loved when you burn Ricky was a
Yankee it was so amazing it was so
glorious and obviously the A's and we go
on and on but let's get to I guess the
story at hand Jeff Passan of ESPN here
on the Rich Eisen show while we're on
the subject guys what's real and what's
Ron not this is real right Major League
Baseball intends to play baseball
in 2020 this is a real conversation any
real possibility Jeff yes this is a very
real thing that I think most of the
stakeholders around the game and we're
talking people in the commissioner's
office for talking players we're talking
executives we're talking those who have
the ability to make that decision
I think together they're all on board
with the idea of playing this year now
there are still hurdles they're going to
be hurdles and you know I sent this
yesterday I was on I was on a dream or
janowski's podcast it was me him and
Adam Schefter and we were just talking
about the different sort of states of
affair with our sports and what it's
going to be like to get them back and
and and the point that I made was
they're gonna be catastrophic screw-ups
along the way because we are just
dealing with the complete unknown and
not only the complete unknown but
something that has the ability to change
direction like Barry Sanders I mean it
could be looking great one day and all
of a sudden you know two minutes later
it's like we're going backward and and
we have to I think it's a society and
the sports themselves be willing to
accept that there may be failures there
may be bad decisions that are made but
ultimately along the way so long as they
are keeping health and safety at the
forefront of their minds rather than
money and profits so long as they're
doing this judiciously and with the
health and safety not just of the
players but the coaches the managers
everybody involved and the American
public in mind I think there is room
rich for sports right now and I think
that the room is complemented by
appetite for it no question about that
Jeff there's no doubt about that
and when you say that the public and
everyone else has to understand that
there could be a monumental screw-up and
it that that wouldn't be we're opening a
human error or the fault of a lack of
planning or incompetence it's just again
the virus acts on its own time and it
acts in its own way and acts in a way
that that that experts in science based
individuals are still trying to figure
out so the question is that what the
players buy-in with the players buy into
all right I'm gonna quarantine for a
month away from wife kids or can I bring
wife kids or are certain teams can you
know not gonna allow wife kids and then
other teams are I mean you know what I'm
saying like they're already we're we're
twisting a Rubik's Cube right here what
about the players Jeff yeah listen we're
twisting a Rubik's Cube rich but as I
can attest my my 12 year old can solve a
Rubik's Cube in about 20 seconds well
that's probably very good ranking by
yanking the pieces out and putting them
back together that's what I did when I
was now he's not he's not one of those
kids who switches to stickers like oh
yeah I'm gonna have to send you a video
when we're heard the air here you're
gonna see you're gonna see this okay
your first reaction is going to be
passing that cannot possibly be your
child I look forward to that right we'll
put on it's pretty it's pretty it's
pretty spectacular here's here's the
thing about the players they hold power
here you know they don't hold all the
cards but they can very easily say if we
don't feel safe if we don't feel
confident in this we're not going to
play the the issue is right now a lot of
the concern on the player side is
financial and that is totally
understandable rich I think in a vacuum
if you feel like you signed a contract
and agree to a deal with Major League
Baseball which the players
Association did that guarantees you and
your mind a particular amount of money
for services rendered and now owners are
saying wait hold on a second we're
probably not going to have fans in the
stands we're not gonna have the revenues
that we thought we were going to so you
might need to take a little haircut
that's not going to sit well with
players and I get that my my hope in
this situation is that all the parties
involved recognize that this is about
more than what an individual whether it
is a player or an owner is doing
financially this is and I hate to make
it bigger than it actually is because
look we're talking about games we're
talking about sports but I think this is
a potentially important thing for the
country and and something that people
really can and should look forward to
not just to have the games back but to
have that sliver of normalcy and it's
going to be an abnormal normal rich it's
going to be games played at the
beginning without fans in the stands
probably in a number of cases in either
minor league or college parks like it's
going to be a little discomforting at
the beginning but but the the
comfortable part we're going to have are
the sounds are the actions are the
things that with which we've grown
familiar throughout the years and that
to me symbolized summer for us and
that's just watching a ball game
regardless of where it is regardless of
how it's being played it's baseball and
if it's back that is better than it not
being note down about a Jeff Passan here
on the Rich Eisen show so walk me
through I know about the the 10 team
divisions I get it but when team
divisions is not real that was ok I was
incorrect
ok so what what is correct and what what
a lot of there are a lot of plans going
on brokering and there are a lot of
things that are being considered that
particular one the details
it just weren't right but there could be
a scenario in which and I think of all
the likely ones this is just me you know
I'm not saying guessing this is kind of
educated guessing but it's also trying
to be logical about it to me the two
plans that seem to work best are the
idea of three three city hubs and five
city hubs and in the three city plan you
wouldn't necessarily have a ten team
division but you could have you know
actual al West and NL West gathering in
Phoenix and the AL Central and NL
Central gathering in the Dallas
metropolitan area in the AL East and the
NL East gathering down in Tampa and you
could have you know for in tradition
games every day and one interleague game
at a complex
I guess at a complex were there are
multiple so let's look at in in Phoenix
for example you know you have at least
one game probably two played at Chase
Field and then you would have three and
spring-training parks surrounding that
whether it's in San Francisco whether
it's at Camelback Ranch you know maybe
they do home games because all the teams
in the NL and Al West have spring
training in Phoenix so they would have
their their home parks that they can
play in in Dallas you could have one
team playing at the new globe Life Park
you could have a game played at TCU you
could have a game played at Dallas
Baptist in my dream world rich Jerry
Jones opens up Jerry world and we have
baseball there how freaking cool would
that be to see a baseball game played at
Jerry well I agree I play I would love
that no doubt about that and
and it would you know and somebody would
have to sign a liability form when the
ball hits the the Jumbotron I mean that
if a punter can hit the bottom of that
thing you know a baseball can I mean
that that would make now that would make
go what you know I guess what the the
catacombs are the Raptors in Tampa you
know look like nothing exactly I'm glad
you bring up Tampa you know you can play
it Tropicana Field the Blue Jays and
didn't even have their spring training
facility right Phillies in Clearwater
have theirs the Yankees sign burner
field you have a Lange field there there
are just enough possibilities to make
those work sure and you also could do
you also could do five cities yes
Houston in Miami to the mix and you have
six teams in each place now how you
split those six teams up that becomes a
little more complicated because you're
not sticking within the division but at
this point it's like we can figure out
those logistical things and if they
don't make sense oh well nothing makes
sense right now like literally nothing
makes sense about the world these days
so why don't we just embrace that lack
of sense and and go on being happy with
the fact that hopefully people are
working to get baseball back on the
field and do so in the safest manner
possible and in terms of that Jeff
Passan senior MLB insider let's get a
little bit more granular then because
you know let's just say the the Yankees
and the Red Sox do play a game in Tampa
right it's not like they give Erin judge
the key and he opens up and then you
know JD Martinez brings his bats for
everybody it's there there's gonna be a
whole huge staff that has to operate the
game and operate the facility how many
people are baseball ready to quarantine
how many people was baseball ready to
put you know in quarantine for a mother
well the big question rich I think is
not how many people are they willing to
quarantine its are they going to
quarantine that bat right now is is part
of this and I think the fact that
they're looking at
Arizona Texas in Florida is not by
accident there are going to be
stay-at-home orders that are lifted if
if not have already been lifted in each
of those states and the idea that they
are going to be opened up
I think appeals in some way to baseball
because I think the notion of quarantine
in in places away from their home was
just a non-starter for too many players
and and when you're trying to hold on
say in this so they're just gonna roll
the dice that it that that everybody's
healthy walking in I mean like harder to
make this work you're going to need to
start with the spring training
I think the spring training is gonna be
spring training 2.0 I've been calling I
think it's gonna be at least three weeks
I thought it was gonna be a little less
but players seem pretty gung-ho that
they need three plus weeks especially
pitchers to ramp back up and during the
during those three weeks I think there's
probably going to be a quarantine period
there where players are going to get
tested pretty consistently where if
anybody shows signs who's going to be
quarantined away from everybody else and
where you're essentially going to get
your baseline right there
I think once they go to the pods if that
is in fact how they do it it's probably
going to be one of those situations
where yes you stay at the hotel yes you
go to the ballpark but I don't think
they're gonna have any anyone outside
checking where players are going at
night for example I don't think they're
going to be severe restrictions in place
I think they're going to say to them be
smart I think they're gonna adhere to
social distancing protocols especially
like you're not going to have guys
hanging out in club houses four hours
before games you're gonna have coaches
especially the the ones who are in their
60s or managers who are in their sixties
or seventies separated from players
pretty significantly like they they have
to be judicious about something like
that because while the
the math tells us and while the
statistics tell us that the the players
who are 20 to 40 years old and typically
in good shape and and without
pre-existing conditions run a fairly low
not a fairly low a very low chance of
having something really deeply affect
them the same can't be said for for the
older men who are going to be involved
here and for for the more vulnerable
ones and that is something you have to
take into account
let me Dusty Baker he's 70 plus right I
mean so yep what if what if a player
says no what if her players like you
know what if honestly what what if what
if what if Gerrit Cole and his 300
million dollars says I don't want to do
it yeah you know I mean honestly gonna
happen with Gerrit Cole I don't think
it's gonna happen but I just I just use
somebody who's really famous and yet is
well-paid necessary for a it is it is
bound to happen with someone and I think
that if if a player is concerned about
his health then it is more than
reasonable for him to say no but I think
the the policy that's being enacted
around the country right now is that if
you're back to work then you're expected
to be at work it's a it's a really hard
thing for workers though to hear that
and I don't envy the player who is going
to have to fight to get his money if he
tries to stay at home and it may may
well end up being a losing battle so
what do you think Jeff time frame it for
me because if we're talking July 2nd
you're talking three weeks of spring
training you're talking about tests I
mean I they're gonna have to test right
I mean like did oh my god gonna test you
know the testing is a huge part of this
you can have everything in place rich
you can have a plan from the league you
can have support from the owners you can
have an agree
with the players you can have facilities
ready you can have a schedule in place
right if you do not have testing not
just testing for the players but enough
testing throughout the country where if
Major League Baseball is is running
through thousands of tests a week maybe
even more that it doesn't look like
they're being taken from those who
really are in need of it if you don't
have that testing and that level of
testing the whole thing Falls Bart Jeff
I appreciate the time man from the
conversation about Ricci which was a a
wonderful
I guess wormhole for us to go be pulled
into to I'm honestly we can go for
another half an hour about the
possibilities of all this stuff
but but it's gonna have to be right now
right like literally mid-may an
announcement will have to be made and
then we're going right to prepare and
trap together I think let's put it this
way there will be an announcement if
something's happening there's going to
be an announcement in May and if there
is not an announcement in May what we're
looking at is a late season World Cup
style tournament okay thanks for the
call Jeff you take care of yourself and
your family and I want that Rubik's Cube
video we'll put it on our social media
filiz if you up for that I
I will I will do that I'm gonna I'm
gonna go bug in and see how fast he can
solve it right now no pressure no
pressure Jeff I honestly don't want that
this homeschooling involvement this
quarantining involved just I want to
make sure everybody's fine in the
passive household okay no no I'm gonna
be like the whiplash it's not my tempo
it's what you start screaming and when
he's trying to do the Rubik's Cube you
take care yourself Jeff father of the
year Jeff there you go right there
you're in the Rich Eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here